want to make sure the sound was good
I am not a Muslim
but I am here to help the
Muslims maybe we'll
see so you you reject the
Trinity I'm on a journey with that um I
don't want to say I reject it but I'm
learning um I did want to ask you about
an argument you make with Muslims
concerning
the uh
Isa uh and the prophecy about the
prophet named Amed if if I'm making
sense if you're you're you're not a
Muslim so it doesn't make sense for you
to defend that yeah this live is about
you guys coming in coming against the
trinity in the Bible bro okay I
understand that then I'll respect the
rules 100% it's your stream um maybe on
on another stream if if you're
addressing that then then I can come up
with that point okay cool all right have
a good one
then Mr Steve you're on stage hello
Avery how are you pretty good good good
um so I I've get accused of being a
modelist um
modelist when I get when I talk to other
trinitarian so um I sort of believe uh
that the father is mind that the son is
body and that the holy spirit is um uh
emotions uh sorry mind body and spirit
um which would correspond with sort of
thoughts actions and emotions so I I
sort of think that God the father had
the thought of creating and then the sun
made the action of actual
creation um and both of them sort of
share the same emotion uh through the
Holy Spirit um so but I don't really
think that any of them can exist
individually sort of as a a person so to
speak because I feel like a body without
a mind wouldn't be good or you know a
mind without a body so I I I struggle
with them sort of being considered
persons I I I prefer to sort of settle
with the aspects element um so how you
know what would you say to that so far
do you do you believe that the father
Son and the Holy Spirit
coexist that they exist together in
communion and
fellowship um yeah um I I think that
there is a separation when um Jesus is
actually in the flesh uh we read in the
Bible that uh the flesh is an emnity
with the SP what about him as the word
what about him before flesh no before
flesh in the word I would say that they
they do have a shared agenda and and I
think that we can sort of see a little
bit of the separation in when Jesus is
praying in the The Garden of Beth a
separation not a separation a a
distinction per se but yeah so do you
believe that the father and the son are
the same person or do you believe
they're distinct and when I say son well
I think I think I don't think that they
are persons individually but aspects of
the same
person yeah so you are a modelist yeah
so I I I kind of see like Jesus as being
an avatar almost like I feel that the
body is an avatar for he's like he's
like a manifestation of of the father
you you believe Jesus is the Father the
holy spirit is the father yeah so yeah
you are modelist yeah
okay so so let me ask you this um are
you familiar with uh with John 8 where
Jesus is talking about um how he
testifies about
himself um certainly with when he says
to Abraham you know uh Abraham begged to
see my day and was glad to see it and he
didn't try to kill me that day before
Abraham I am I believe that that that's
particularly referencing his visitation
with melkisedek when they had the Bread
and Wine yeah I'm not asking about that
I'm not asking about that um so let me I
I'll pull up the verse to show you what
I'm talking
about all right so
excuse
me all
right all right so it's on the right
side this is John chapter 8 on the right
yep um I'll start at verse 16 it says
uh yet even if I do judge my judgment is
true for it is not I alone who judge but
I and the father who sent me all right
yeah in your law it is written that the
testimony of two people is true
true I am one who Bears witness about
myself and the
father all right so for Jesus he's
making a point to the Jews right that
his testimony is true according to the
law because according to the law need
the testimony of two
persons
yeah so he's one that he's one testimony
one witness and his father is another
witness so I I would say in response to
that that the way that the father is
witnessing for him is through the
Miracles that he is performing so that
is it's not I know that um obviously the
father at one point when when Jesus is
baptized he speaks down and says you
know this is my son who whom I am
pleased and on the Mount of
transfiguration um so in that sense you
know I I the the father um is
uh is testifying for him but um I don't
know if the people that he's speaking to
there would have witnessed that or
necessarily understand but I think that
um they they would have been aware of of
his miracles and and sort of seeing that
as yeah I agree I I agree that there's
so you have the father who not only
Bears witness about Jesus Through The
Works that he does through him yeah but
also he audibly Bears witness about him
and says this is my son whom I will
please listen to him he does that
multiple times right so those are
different ways that the father Bears
witness about Jesus um but the point is
is that he is a witness of Jesus right
he's bearing witness of Jesus yeah and
then Jesus as well Bears witness of
himself of himself y yeah so you have
two persons here according to the law to
make his testimony true the two persons
at least are required and the two
persons that he identifies as his
Witnesses are himself and his father is
the
other so I I think they're two two
distinct persons could could we could we
sort of look at that as um you can
actually logically understand that there
is a God by observing the creation so
that you've got logic which is not uh uh
physical it
it's something other than physical but
then you've got the physical reality
so there you you've kind of got two
witnesses but it's it's they're
encompassed in in one thing in a way
yeah but not that wouldn't be according
to the law see like you can you can have
um like anthropomorphic Witnesses like
in the Bible it talks about how there
are three that bear record in heaven
right the the water the word and the
blood yeah right or the spirit but um
yeah that that's that's talking more
theological more you know spiritual this
is talking about according to the law so
this is doing this is in true matters of
what makes a testimony true a person
someone's testimony so yeah this is for
the rationale for the Jewish mind when
when when he's talking to somebody that
has got their their roots in the Jewish
law then they are looking for those two
witnesses exactly so yeah so then so for
him to not be lying to us and also to be
in accordance to the law and that they
can't you know yeah accuse him of
anything it has to be true that he is
one person who witnesses about himself
and the father is another person who
witnesses about him and he but he he
could have also brought up somebody like
um John the Baptist who who Jesus says
Was
Elijah um so there is other witnesses as
well that's true yeah the father is not
his only witness he he he he even says
that Moses is his witness as well for he
writ about him again these are these are
people these are or persons these are
persons yeah I suppose I I I I I do
understand that they they are are sort
of separate persons in the they witness
there but for myself as I tried to sort
of explain I I have two witnesses for
myself that I can see with my eyes the
the world and I understand it in my mind
so when I see who are your two
wit well my eyes tell me and and my mind
can my Consciousness can confirm what my
eyes see will that will that work in the
court of
law I um I'm I'm not sure if I
understand what you mean by working in a
law if you were to come right and let's
say um let's say you're being questioned
something right yeah you need you need
an alibi they're like do you have an you
know an alibi is when you know someone
can testify so that that can be The
Logical reason the the the Consciousness
part and then if I had a video evidence
like something see with eyes yeah you
don't have any video evidence will it
work in a court of law if you say well
judge I don't have anyone that can
verify my whereabouts but I do have two
witnesses I have my eyes I think I think
that one of my witnesses that I'm
claiming is the video evidence that's
what I can you don't have any you don't
have video there there is no video well
for me I'm I'm trying to parallel the
video evidence with the actual physical
unit don't my friend do you know but we
have a physical follow the analogy with
me can you can you follow the analogy
with me
please sorry the the physical Universe
in in my analogy is the
videotape so we can actually see see
physical reality a as a videotape okay
and and then we all right bro um it
sounds like you're not I don't know if
you're I don't I don't know what's going
on with you I don't know if you're
willing to you know follow what we're
saying yeah as I say I'm not sure if I
understand not having the the video if
you are in the court if you're in the
court of law and you need a an alibi the
court the judge asks you do you have a
witness to verify your whereabouts while
this took place this crime took place
will it work in the court of law if you
said yes judge
I myself my eyes is one witness and my
mind can also witness for me that I was
where I was in in the scenario that
you're putting forward no I don't think
it would okay I I I don't think that's a
very good analogy of the situation with
Jesus because Jesus is talking about
according to the law it's multiple
persons the testimony of M person that
make a witness true right so here he's
not oh well guys my mind is one witness
and my eyes are the other that's that's
not how it works you need another person
outside of yourself that verifies what
you're saying ACC I'll get what you're
saying there so so yeah you need two
persons and and Jesus is is specifically
declaring the the father as one of those
second persons yeah exactly so so so he
can't he and the father can't be the
same person
if his testimony is to be true according
to the law they have to be two distinct
persons
yeah yeah I I see what you're saying and
and there is another issue that I get
sort of tripped up on a little bit which
is where um the Holy Spirit actually
gives gifts as it chooses as he as he as
he as he chooses and I I in my analogy I
I struggle to sort of I I because also
blasphemy against the holy spirit is the
one unforgivable sin and and I sort of
thought that's because in a way the holy
spirit is is it doesn't do anything it's
just there as a sort of an
emotion but does actually seem to give
give gifts yeah not not only does he
give spiritual gifts my brother he also
gives commands and he places people
where they need to be in the church like
for example let me um you have Acts
chapter
13 um watch what the holy spirit says
here this is actually fascinating so you
have acts
13 and I'm G put on the screen for
us so look here it says we read verse
one and verse
two now there were in the Church of at
Antioch prophets and teachers Barnabas
Simeon who was called Niger Lucius of
sirene
uh Manan a lifelong friend of Herod the
tetrarch and Saul while they were
worshiping the Lord and fasting the holy
spirit
said set apart for me right so the holy
spirit is speaking and then saying set
apart for me so this is for me the holy
spirit is saying for my pleasure set
apart for me Barnabas and Saul for the
work to which I I have called
them so the Holy Spirit not just gives
gifts but he commands and he
appoints right he speaks he
communicates yeah quite complex for an
aspect I suppose exactly you know a
concept can't speak and call people and
and give them jobs right electricity
can't be pleased by the job that you do
and for something do you believe that
any one of the um three parts of the
godhead can exist without the other all
right so we don't believe that there
that these are parts of the god here God
is well sorry the person do you think do
you think the father can exist without
the son or do you think the son could
exist without the father for example
when when Jesus died on the cross I
believe the father raised him up but I
don't believe that the father could die
and be raised by the son well the father
didn't take on flesh so that's why so
the father didn't take on a nature that
he can die in and then be raised up yeah
the that's why so the Sun so to to
answer your question no they cannot
exist outside of each other the father
begets the Son and the Holy Spirit um
proceeds from the father's Essence and
think that's all it's all one you know
yeah and that that's that's why I
struggle with the the personhood versus
aspect because if one can't exist
without the other I feel like it would
be an incomplete person whereas
if if if you can't have the father
without the son then the father alone is
incomplete not it's not the complete if
if the Trinity the three parts equal 100
he's not identical to the no so this is
what you maybe are getting to the father
the the persons are not identical to the
Divine Essence right these are two
different categories the Divine Essence
and then the persons are two different
categories I think I've realized where
or went wrong yeah so carry on sorry
yeah so so the persons are not identical
to the essence those are two different
categories there so
um like that's that's they're not Parts
they're not you know they are who they
are and what they are right the Father
the Son and the spirit
as persons are not identical to the
essence they share the same Essence the
Son and the spirit proceed and come
forth from the father's Essence right
yeah so and and yeah quickly with with
the essence
element uh I mentioned uh that the son
in the flesh would have that emnity
against the spirit and the the will of
Jesus was he actually prayed you know uh
not my will but your
so would you accept that there is
actually a slight change in essence when
the word took on flesh no there's not a
change in essence he took on a a second
nature so his Divine Essence doesn't
change he just added on and took on a
second nature which is human so he's
then got both rather he has both that's
that's that's what the hypostatic union
is so yeah so I suppose I mean the last
thing I would say is is that because I I
feel like a person is constructed of of
mind body and spirit MH that all three
elements are sort of
required would be required in each part
so Jesus would require a mind body and
spirit which which I believe he does yes
this is where I I think that you're
conflating person and human being a
human being is comprised of mind body
and spirit well person but not
necessarily person is just a conscious
agent that has a mind that has a will
that has emotions that self-aware that's
what personhood is that's what a person
is so so for you a person doesn't
require a body as such correct a per a
person could be a two two-part duality
of you you describe the Consciousness
and a will so maybe just Consciousness
mind yeah that's that's what a person is
a body is not quired yeah yeah all right
well interesting good good talking to
you probably try and push the point but
I'll I'll leave it there um I did send
you an email um it I've titled it the
tree of knowledge of Good and Evil um if
if you manag to one day look for you've
probably got thousands of emails I got a
lot um but I I would be I feel like you
you would uh uh value from it um so it's
uh it's it's in your email list um I
said it three or four days ago um the
tree of knowledge of Good and Evil is
titled and uh yeah thank you for your
time thank you for coming I appreciate
you right cheers man have a good and be
well God bless God bless you God bless
you all
right hero Israel the Lord Our God the
Lord is one and then Matthew you'll be
after hero
Israel hello how you doing I'm pretty
good how are you good
good you reject the
Trinity yes that's my name suggest your
name doesn't suggest that you reject the
Trinity yeah yeah it does
how Israel the Lord Our God the Lord is
one how does that Def One how do you
define
one how is one defined there in that in
that verse no not how do you define one
it doesn't matter how I Define to the
verse yeah let's first establish what
one means and then we'll get to the
verse yeah let's establish what one
means in the verse that you're talking
about what does one mean establish what
one means before you look into the verse
so you have a criteria to work off of so
what does one mean my my criteria is the
scripture so according to the verse that
you're saying is in your name that
rejects the Trinity here Israel the Lord
Our God the Lord is one what does one
mean in that
verse exactly what it says it means one
what do you mean exactly what okay for
example um it says in Genesis chapter 2
that man is going to leave his mother
mother and father cleave to his wife and
the two shall become one flesh they
there did they actually become one flesh
yeah what does one mean
there yeah it's figurative but it's not
the same you can understand why it's the
same why it's not the same how is it why
is it not the same the the word is the
same did they literally become one
what's the what's the Hebrew word you
don't work off of the word you work off
of the context did they literally become
oh you don't work off the word you work
off the context good yes so ask it again
look this this is my point bro so we we
see that one can be a Unity One can also
be numerically absolutely singularly one
right the context will tell you how does
Deuteronomy 64 hero Israel the Lord Our
God the Lord is
onead how does that verse reject the
Trinity because it says
one you
okay me yeah yes you
sure yes okay it says that man and woman
become one flesh does it does it neglect
the fact that they are two
persons no like I said that's how you
derive the context they didn't literally
become one flesh so that's how you know
when that word is used it doesn't mean
one oh wait wait a second what do you
mean they didn't literally become one
what are you talking about it literally
says they become
yeah it says one it says they become one
flesh it says one again you have to use
the context of the situation if you see
literally become one very good I'll do
so I'll ask you again how does
Deuteronomy
64 reject the Trinity because simply
saying one God is one doesn't do it you
need context so where in the context of
Deuteronomy 6:4 does it tell you that
Yahweh is One Singular person
well like I said when you look at the
context it just means one where in the
context does it demonstrate that Yahweh
is One Singular
person well like I said it's just the
context as a whole when you when you
read the verse there's nothing in the
verse that would suggest that it means
other than
one because the verse has the the the
word itself as definition always means
literally
one thanks for
coming Matthew how you
doing you're
muted you
muted oh yeah it's good brother I'm
alive with a job how you doing alive
with a job